what's like your favorite Christmas song
If you had to pick one like a classic
anything by Michael blé and you oh I
love Michael blé I know I love he sounds
like he is Christmas that sounds I like
The Ronettes every year my parents play
the Rett like it's a great record that's
what my no maybe we should sing you you
brought up silent night and I feel like
we're all three singers sing We have a
we have
a oh no
oh here's here's the best
part there has been no rehearsal we've
never so this could go very poorly but I
feel confident we've never yeah we've
never done this or rehears this but
going to be great I don't know maybe G
maybe G okay you start and then we'll
chime in this is going to be great
sure
night
holy night
all
is all
is
[Music]
mother so
T
sleep heav Heavenly
peace see
in that was for
[Applause]
you I love
that we are
talented
[Applause]
[Music]
forer thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home